there's a very important relationship
between iron
and your hair your nails
and your skin now the very interesting
thing about this trace mineral in that
we have no
internal mechanism
to regulate
the elimination of iron so just as a
deficiency of iron can be very very
devastating an excess of iron can be
very very devastating but our body does
have certain mechanisms depriving
microbes of pathogens because almost all
pathogens
need iron to survive
and so there is this huge competition of
iron between our pathogens and our own
cells but that's going to be for a
separate video today we're going to talk
about the effects of iron on our hair
nails and skin and so many people are
deficient in iron i would say worldwide
it's about a billion people
yet when you're diagnosed with an iron
deficiency
you're told to take elemental iron
elemental iron is not the best form of
iron for absorption and so many times
when you take it you're waiting for
these symptoms to clear up but it never
does and then you ask your doctor well
what's the root cause why am i iron
deficient and they might say well you're
just anemic all right then
why do i have anemia in the first place
so i'm going to cover that but let's
first talk about how iron affects your
hair nails and skin all right as far as
the skin goes when you're deficient in
iron it has huge consequences
number one it creates a type of skin
called sallow skin which is a pale
slightly yellowish
kind of a dull complexion you're
basically going to lose that bright
complexion and now you'll have this
uneven skin tone
that you'll see little blemishes you'll
see sometimes little red dots but
overall a lack of iron really affects
your overall complexion on your face now
as far as your nails go
you may find that your nails are brittle
and if you're chronically deficient in
iron you're going to get that little
spooning of the nail it's going to look
a little bit like the nail is scooped
out so brittle nails and a spoon shaped
nail all right what about the hair well
the hair is going to lose its texture
it's going to become
brittle kind of tough and you'll see
pattern hair loss now
in men that is
loss of hair on the top of the head in
females pattern hair loss is basically
thinning of the hair
all over and so a lack of iron is one
big cause of that and females are more
deficient in iron than men because they
have their menstrual periods every month
and they lose a lot of blood and because
iron is part of hemoglobin and
hemoglobin is part of blood when you
lose blood you lose iron iron is needed
for oxygen and so if you're not able to
have enough oxygen
to your hair
your nails or your skin
all sorts of things can happen so how do
you become deficient in iron well one is
you're not taking enough iron in to the
diet now the problem with iron in diet
is that there's two forms of iron you
have heme iron and non-heme iron and
this relates to the efficiency of how
iron is
absorbed in your body when you consume
iron from things like spinach or beans
the absorption is much much less
like spinach has an absorption rate of
like 1.5
beans are like 2.2
but then when we get to
like beef liver the absorption is like
15 then when we get to red meat we're
talking about absorption rate of 21. so
if we compare the non-heme source
roughly at a two and a heme source with
red meat at a 21 you can see there's a
vast
difference so consuming animal meat is
going to give you a lot more
iron and i highly recommend you get your
iron from food versus a supplement
because the elemental iron that they
give you in supplements is just
it's just it's crap it's low quality
it's not the type of iron that nature is
providing you now if you absolutely
cannot
eat red meat for some reason then i
would recommend getting it from maybe a
supplement that's a
dehydrated
beef liver
or even a spleen
extract from an animal all right the
next thing i want to talk about
is your stomach if your stomach does not
have enough hydrochloric acid okay this
is very common you're not going to
absorb iron because the acid in the
stomach
makes the iron soluble to be absorbed so
if someone doesn't have enough acid or
they're taking an acids because they
have heartburn or whatever or gerd
that could be the reason why they're not
absorbing iron and the interesting thing
about not having enough hydrochloric
acid to absorb iron is you're probably
not going to have enough hydrochloric
acid to digest red meat either and i
will get to a solution for that but you
just need to know that a lack of stomach
acid can create a media now another
common cause is that
your colon
or your small intestine is inflamed okay
any type of inflammatory
gut issue will block the absorption of
iron as in ibs
crohn's diverticulitis
irritable bowel syndrome etc etc so
inflammation can definitely be a problem
and so the number one cause of
inflammation in the gut
is there certain foods that you're
eating number one grains omega-6 fatty
acids in grains
or like things like soy oil or corn oil
or canola oil or cottonseed oil which is
in pretty much all the foods especially
if you go out to dinner and you eat
something fried you're going to have a
lot of omega-6 fatty acids and that's
going to create inflammation in your gut
and some people are sensitive to nuts
and seeds and
even chocolate
and sometimes even coffee beans and
those things can create inflammation as
well so if a person is eating a lot of
peanut butter for example and they feel
a lot of
bloating or stomach pain that could be
an indication that you have inflammation
in your gut all right the other thing
that can block iron is something called
phytic acid which is in grains beans
legumes so if you consume a lot of
cereal for example
that could be the reason why you're not
absorbing iron because of all this
phytic acid if you germinate
nuts like let's say you soak them
overnight and then you dehydrate them
that will get rid of a lot of the phytic
acid or if you sprout the seed you get
rid of the phytic acid also
too much bran the fiber in grains
can block iron as well as too much
copper if you're taking a lot of copper
that can block iron and also if you have
lead in your body that can block iron
all right and the next one is blood loss
so menstruation is a common cause of
blood loss
if you have an ulcer that could be a
cause or if there's any other type of
bleeding inside your gut
that could be a cause of loss of iron
like let's say you had
cancer for example in your colon you're
bleeding and you're wondering why your
stool is dark red well that could be the
reason
if you had gastric bypass okay
that could be the reason why you're not
absorbing iron and the last reason is
alcohol okay if you drink alcohol on a
regular basis that could be the reason
why you are deficient in iron all right
so here are things you need to do number
one start consuming red meat if you can
okay
now number two
this is going to handle the ph problem
with the stomach you need to start
taking something called betaine
hydrochloride
that's going to acidify the stomach and
that's going to allow you to digest the
red meat okay and it's going to help you
absorb iron so more animal meats
and
betaine hydrochloride to acidify the
stomach and i would also recommend if
you're going to take retained
hydrochloride to take
uh five to six maybe even seven before a
meal because i found you have to take a
little bit more of it to really have it
work it will take a period of weeks
maybe even months to fully correct all
right next thing is to stop eating the
foods
that are blocking iron
foods that have phytic acid like the
grains the nuts the seeds
those can be a problem
and stop eating things that are creating
inflammation that's blocking your gut
and that would be
the grains primarily and things that are
high in omega 6 fatty acids and i think
the best video for you to watch next
would be to get more information on that
topic
so i put it up right here check it out